thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
in early 1848 a humble carpenter by the
name of james marshall made a discovery
that would change the course of american
history he was working on a
water-powered lumber mill in what was
soon to become california for pioneer
john sutter when he saw it the merest
glimpse of twinkling metal tucked away
in the bucket of the mills water wheel
it was a nugget of solid gold
demonstrating either remarkable honesty
or baffling stupidity depending on how
well your moral compass is functioning
today marshall immediately took that
lump of gold to his boss to begin with
sutter tried to keep the discovery quiet
but it was only a matter of time before
people began to talk and within a matter
of months stories of gold in sutter's
creek had spread like herpes in a mining
camp one of the first men to react to
the news was san franciscan entrepreneur
sam brannan who traveled to sutter's
creek snagged himself a vial filled with
gold then headed back to san francisco
where he walked the streets with the
vial held high above his head announcing
to the world that there was gold in the
american river fast forward a few months
to june 1848 and three quarters of san
francisco's male population had left for
the gold mines
a year later the number of settlers in
california had exploded from 400 to 90
you might think finding a river full of
gold on your property is just about the
luckiest thing that could ever happen
but by 1852 just four years later sutter
was bankrupt his farm had been invaded
by prospectors
and all his livestock was stolen sam
brennan on the other hand was making
five thousand dollars a day that's about
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars a
day in today's money and was soon to
become california's first millionaire
and the state's richest man and all that
despite never digging for an ounce of
gold instead before sparking the frenzy
that became the great california gold
rush brannon had invested in mining
equipment and selling it during the
ensuing frenzy at exorbitant prices
now if you love traveling then you'll
love the fastest and easiest vpn surf
shark did you know surf shark helps you
to avoid price discrimination based on
your location
so you can save money on plane tickets
and car rentals whilst traveling
surfshark runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch if your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support by using surfsharkvpn
you can stay anonymous and secure online
personally i use surfshark to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk
it's so easy all i have to do is switch
over my location settings and there i
have it access to all my favorite
programs surfshark maintains a strict no
logs policy and their network of 3200
servers in over 65 countries runs 100
on ram so they couldn't log your data
even if they wanted to by using code 42
you will benefit from an 83 discount
plus free extra months for free
all you have to do is click the special
link in the description below don't miss
out
in a gold rush it's seldom the miners
who make the real money it's the people
selling
the idea
170 years on and not much has changed
except now the gold rush has gone
digital instead of mining for metal
people are mining cryptocurrency since
the launch of bitcoin in 2009
cryptocurrencies have gradually
transformed from being things that geeks
used to buy pizza to financial
instruments that are being taken
seriously by big tech and world
governments it's been one hell of a
roller coaster ride and if you were
lucky enough to have been on board from
the beginning
you're now probably very very rich if he
bought 10 bitcoins in 2010
the most you would have paid was 3.90
today those coins would be worth almost
half a million dollars
it's statistics like these that have
created a crypto craze among certain
investors looking for big returns but
just like in the california gold rush
for every crypto investor who made a
fortune
many more have ended up out of pocket
and just like in the gold rush the
people who rake in the big cash
are usually the ones who create the
demand that's why there are more than 9
000 active cryptocurrencies and
circulation all over the place 21st
century sam brannon's are parading
digital glass bottles
they say are full of gold
unsurprisingly with so many people
desperately hoping to be amongst the
early adopters of the next big thing the
number of crypto scams has risen
dramatically in recent years too
some of these are dodgy startups whilst
others are fake initial coin offerings
or icos inico is used by new crypto
projects to raise the cash they need to
get going in exchange for their money
early investors receive tokens in the
project if that project is successful
those tokens could be worth huge sums of
money in the future but of course if the
ico is a scam you'll never see your
hard-earned dollars again
amits lachen pal founder of money trade
coin is alleged to have knowingly run a
fake ico defrauding investors out of an
eye-watering
71 million dollars in another scheme in
taiwan 1 000 investors were defaulted
out of 51 million dollars whilst in
canada authorities seized luxury cars
and froze bank accounts owned by the
ring leaders of fuel an allegedly
fraudulent 22 million dollar ico from
2017. as ballsy as these coins are they
don't hold a digital candle to the one
run by roya ignatova
self-styled crypto queen and creator of
the biggest cryptocurrency scam
in history
one coin
launched in 2014 one coin loading
hundreds of thousands of eager buyers
with promises of revolutionizing the
crypto industry and making millionaires
out of everyone he was smart enough to
invest early by the middle of 2017
onecoin had reached 175 countries and
was estimated to have attracted as much
as 12 billion pounds of investment from
around 1 million people ignatova was the
rockstar front for the operation oxford
educated and once a financial consultant
for the highly respected management
consultancy mckinsey ignatova seemed to
have the credibility to back her grand
claims
that onecoin would soon make bitcoin and
all the other cryptocurrencies obsolete
she toured the world filling stadiums
with evangelical investors convinced
that onecoin was the future of world
finance and their ticket to
extraordinary wealth every step of the
way ignatova projected an image of
success wearing expensive gowns and
covering herself in diamonds tom jones
even sang at her birthday party but then
in october 2017
at the height of her fame
she vanished
that was more than four years ago and
she hasn't been seen or heard from since
as is normally the case when people go
missing the authorities have been
scouring the planet for the crypto queen
but roya ignatova is far more than just
another face on a milk carton she's
wanted by the fbi and has been charged
by u.s authorities for wire fraud
securities fraud and money laundering
and this isn't even her first time in
2012 she was convicted of fraud in
germany and in 2013 she was part of a
major crypto scam called big coin you'd
think that might have rung a few alarm
bells during the whole onecoin thing but
apparently not
in the time since roya's disappearance
her brother and right hand man in the
onecoin operation constantine ignatov
was arrested
since then he's pleaded guilty to money
laundering and fraud it turns out that
far from being a revolutionary new
digital currency
one coin was just a good old-fashioned
ponzi scheme dressed up in sexy clothes
one of the things that made onecoin so
appealing to so many people was that it
seemed so simple cryptocurrency can seem
pretty confusing to the uninitiated but
with onecoin all investors had to do was
transfer some cash and in return they'd
received some onecoin in a personal
online account according to ignatova
this process wasn't just easier than
buying and owning bitcoin it was safer
too
and for those reasons she prophesied
that the value of onecoin would only
increase
she was right any onecoin investor
watching their online account between
2014 and 2017 would have seen the value
of their investment
rising rapidly exciting stuff
but unfortunately for those investors
also total
if you want to buy bitcoin or ethereum
or any other credible cryptocurrency
you usually do it on one of the big
crypto exchanges just like on the stock
market where share prices go up and down
according to fluctuations in supply and
demand the price you pay for a
cryptocurrency at any point in time is
determined by the mystical operations of
free market economics if a
cryptocurrency builds trust and
credibility its price can be expected to
increase over time as investors jump
aboard which is exactly what one coin
investors believed was happening to
their currency what they didn't know
however was that the price of onecoin
wasn't linked to
anything despite promises to the
contrary one coin couldn't be traded
anywhere outside the onecoin system so
it had no market value
and couldn't even be exchanged for cash
the price of onecoin
was meaningless it was just a number
invented by someone sitting at a
computer in the company's head office in
sofia bulgaria
one coin investors believed they were
making thousands even millions of
dollars on their initial investment
in reality that investment was long gone
it turns out onecoin wasn't really a
cryptocurrency at all
it wasn't even based on blockchain
technology it was essentially a pet
project
running on a bunch of servers in the
onecoin head office in sofia eventually
some people started to question whether
onecoin was really everything it claimed
to be but by then it had morphed into
some kind of cult and those inside
simply weren't interested in hearing
anything that questioned ignatova's
message
people who owned onecoin were convinced
they were part of a family and any
outsider who questions the currency was
a hater he was jealous of having missed
a boat
the system of indoctrination worked so
well because the one coin craze was
fueled by multi-level marketing where
participants make commission by selling
a product on to their friends and family
who in turn sell to their friends and
family and so on if you're thinking
pyramid scheme you're pretty much there
roya ignatova got some of the world's
top multi-level marketers to promote
onecoin and the network grew incredibly
fast the ensuing buzz made sure that
investors eager to cash in on the
opportunity asked fewer questions and
brought into the fake gold rush hook
line and sinker
according to journalist jamie bartlett
who uncovered the story one coin was
more like a religion than an investment
opportunity those who asked too many
questions were threatened with expulsion
from the onecoin family and the loss of
their investment
but by the middle of 2017 no amount of
hush hush could prevent the net from
closing in around ignatova the fbi was
preparing to arrest her but it appears
she got wind of the plan in advance
because towards the end of that year on
the day she was due to attend an event
in lisbon she boarded a plane for athens
and simply disappeared of course she
didn't leave empty-handed according to
court documents and witness testimonies
ignitova made off with at least 500
million dollars and 230 000 bitcoins
worth about 10 billion dollars today
there are many competing theories as to
where she's gone 10 billion dollars and
change is enough money to do pretty much
anything and go pretty much anywhere
some people believe ignatova changed her
appearance with plastic surgery and is
living in luxury possibly in frankfurt
germany under an assumed identity others
put her in russia or possibly dubai
when testifying at his own trial in 2019
constantine ignatova claimed to have no
idea where his sister was
only that the men who met her at the
athens airport
spoke russian
of course it's also possible that
ignatova's criminal activity finally
caught up with her and she's simply been
taken care of so to speak unless she
turns up one way or another we're
unlikely to know for sure
amazingly one coin continued to operate
for another two years after ignatova
disappeared even after her brother had
been arrested and her lawyer mark scott
had been found guilty of laundering 400
million dollars of onecoin's cash by the
end of 2019 the house of cards had
finally collapsed but that won't be the
end of this story as one crypto scam
folds another is bound to take its place
if history has taught us anything it's
that people can't resist a gold rush
thanks for watching